vite les gars vous vous souvenez comment
c'était avant
tu veux dire quand on était dans la
boîte non avant notre naissance l'usiné
sucrière tout ça quoi
moi je m'en souviens moteur mais non tu
vas voir c'est une chouette histoire il
ya des effets spéciaux du suspense on
sera même des héros et les moulins ont
nié regarde des cachalots importe la can
qui va être transformé en sucre à
l'usiné dans les usines la can et
charrier sur ce tapis roulant pour
fabriquer du sucre il faut préparer
cette can
on commence par la couper en petits
loups dans le cantal un appareil avec
des dizaines de l'âme qui tour inquiète
pas la can ne sent rien et c'est tant
mieux parce que ce n'est que le début
ensuite la can continue son chemin de
machines en machine sur le tapis roulant
ça c'est le chiffre et d'air
la can il est broyé en tout petits
morceaux elle passe entre d'énormes
martin ci tourne et licra contre une
partie fixe l'enclos à les remets toi on
continue didon c'est encore loin non on
y est presque
oh et puis zut à temps c'est pas fini
fais attention
oui ou non elle fait drôlement mal ton
histoire je t'avais prévenu
nous sommes au séparateur magnétique
c'est un gros aimant tisseyre retenir
tous les objets métalliques qui traîne
et pourrait endommager les machines de
la sucrerie
je retire ce que j'ai dit elle est super
bien ton histoire très drôle et pourquoi
l'image est floue attends je remets mes
lunettes dont j'en étais ou à huy après
il y a le moulin rouge où c'est là où y
récolter le jus oui ça je connais c'est
presque ça mais en beaucoup plus grand
lac avait pressé entre ces énormes
rouleaux ouvre en extraire le jus
le gie de cannes va servir à faire le
sucre mais comme pour le jus d'orange
par exemple il reste des déchets c'est
la bagasse en la brûlant dans une
centrale thermique au produit de
l'électricité qui permet d'alimenter des
maisons partout à la réunion
ensuite on retrouve le jus séparer de la
bagasse vous allez voir ce qu'ils rêvent
tout beau le jus brut est encore remplie
de minuscules fibre il faut donc le
nettoyeur taplin de vagal dans le nez
chez toi la tête de bagages je disais
donc il faut nettoyer le jus alors on le
fait couler dans une sorte d'énorme
passoire mais les petits morceaux il
passe à travers
alors pour les attraper c'est plus
compliqué mais comment on fait pour
commencer on fait monter la température
du jeu à 70 degrés celsius dans le
réchauffeur ensuite le jeu est envoyé
dans le show l'heure c'est une pub où
l'on rajoute de la chaux une poudre qui
va permettre d'attraper toutes les
particules puis se mélangent pas dans un
bac de décantation appelé aussi
clarificateur on rajoute quelques
molécules bien collante
elles vont s'agripper aux impuretés
rassemblés par la chaux et le tout est
transformé en boue mais alors tu
transformes du bon jeu en bon quoi on y
de la boue sucré mais non la boue c'est
les celtes et collés ensemble qui
finissent au fond de la cuve le jus de
canne plus légers restent au dessus bien
trop près je préfère ça le jus caire
continue son chemin dans l' usine alors
que la boue va être transformés en
engrais on appelle ça légumes
le gicl est réprimée guide car il
contient beaucoup d'eau ou le choc pour
que l'eau s'évapore comme ça on obtient
les plus liquides surnommée le sirop la
cuisse gauche alors il faut encore
chauffer le ciron dans un appareil qui
ressemble à l'évaporateur c'est le
cuiseur c'est lui qui transforme le
sirop de l'évaporateur en sucre favreau
2 1
d'accord mais comment ils font pour
qu'on soit tous de la même taille ah oui
pour avoir des cristaux de taille
identique on ajoute dans le cuiseur
quelques grains de sucre le sirop les
recopie pour qu'ils aient tous la même
taille c'est la cristallisation aussi
magique mais tout le juge ne se
cristallise pas on se retrouve donc avec
un mélange de sucre et de sirop appelé
masque 8 pour les séparer on va laisser
couler comme dans une sorte d'énorme
essoreuse à salade
c'est là sans preuve
dans la centrifugeuse le sirop se sépare
en deux parties d'un côté il y à la
mélasse
elle va servir à la fabrication du rhum
dans une distillerie spécialisés mais
aussi comme complément alimentaire pour
les vaches l'autre tuyaux amène le sucre
vers aimé viala vous et doux
oh
et puis ton fillon
pas mal pas mal mais au fait d'où elles
viennent nos couleurs à ça c'est une
question de cuisson est de taille de
grains cela permet d'avoir des arômes
différents
tiens toi par exemple tu es celui qui se
rapproche le plus des arômes de la can
gens ne te sûr et donc nous voilà avec
un kilo de cannes ont fait 22 morceaux
de sucre comme nom moi je suis surtout
content de ne pas avoir fini en bad ass
ou dans le nez de sucre blond ouais
ouais
la prochaine fois je vous laisse écrasé
dans le choix des monteurs